[Applauso]
[Musica]
Se aveste l'opportunità di incontrare i
voi stessi del futuro
pensate che ci andreste d'accordo che vi
riconoscereste
quante volte capita di pensare a come si
sia arrivati a determinate decisioni a
come si siano affrontate alcune
situazioni e non capire come sia stato
possibile quasi fossero decisioni azioni
di un'altra persona
Ad esempio se ripensate le vostre
relazioni passate non vi capita mai di
non riconoscervi nella persona che
eravate in quelle relazioni
oppure quante volte da adolescenti
abbiamo urlato contro i nostri genitori
tu non mi capisci ma se ci pensiamo ad
oggi non ci riconosciamo neppure noi
stessi se ci penseresti penso Povera la
mia mamma
nella pratica la persona che siamo oggi
non è la stessa che eravamo nel passato
e quella che saremo nel futuro
tutti cambiamo e cambiamo continuamente
che lo vogliamo meno in maniera
consapevole o non consapevole
immaginiamo il corso della nostra vita
come un fiume scorre inevitabilmente
influenzato da Fattori esterni che ne
determinano delle mutazioni
quando piove c'è più acqua scorrerà più
velocemente quando cecità farà più
fatica ad andare avanti e In entrambe
queste situazioni non potrà esercitare
alcuna forma di controllo
noi possiamo scegliere se percorrere il
fiume che è una perfetta metafora della
vita o restando in balia della corrente
come se fossimo un legnetto che si
lascia trasportare oppure provando a
mettere delle radici profonde in un
punto preciso del nostro percorso come
se fossimo un albero che fa una fatica
enorme perché tutto rimanga come me ma
il fiume scorre e il mondo intorno a noi
cambia inevitabilmente inclinando
l'albero e trascinando il legnetto
forse il modo migliore per percorrere il
fiume e trovare una barca Una barca che
ci consenta di indirizzare in maniera
consapevole il nostro percorso
sono stata un albero per nove anni mi
sono laureata in ingegneria ho lavorato
in azienda
avevo le mie certezze è una visione del
futuro molto chiara tutto molto lineare
Poi a un certo punto ho capito che non
era quello che desideravo volevo
qualcosa di più volevo lavorare a
qualcosa di mio che mi motivasse e che
creasse un impatto positivo
scegliere una nuova strada però avrebbe
significato abbandonare tutte le
certezze che avevo sviluppato fino a
quel momento e in quel momento avevo
proprio bisogno di una barca e la mia
barca è stata lo yoga
anche per me anzi per noi le cose non
sono andate in maniera poi così diversa
Ci siamo iscritti all'università senza
però sapere cosa volevamo fare da grandi
l'abbiamo fatta con impegno e dedizione
però L'obiettivo non era chiaro
l'architetto la negoziatrice
internazionale
non lo sappiamo una vita un po' da
legnetto Insomma trascinate dalla
corrente del fiume
alla fine del percorso di studi Perché
quando le cose si fanno si vanno bene È
venuto ciò che ha portato noi essere
quello che siamo oggi
l'incontro con lo yoga e l'incontro fra
di noi che ci ha poi portato anche a
fondare la nostra azienda
lo Yoga ci ha fatto vedere che ci stanno
facendo trascinare dalla corrente della
vita che quello che avevamo non ci
bastava
anche per noi lo Yoga è stato e continua
ad essere la nostra barca
Che cos'è lo yoga
starete pensando a acrobazie e
contorsionismi corpi elastici posizioni
impossibili perché vabbè scrollando sui
social adesso distrattamente Magari è
questo che ci viene in mente non andremo
a farmi un corso accelerato sulle teorie
di questa disciplina antichissima quello
che vorremmo Però trasmettervi a quello
che lo Yoga ha rappresentato e
rappresenta per noi
Spesso sul tappetino
Si affrontano delle situazioni che sono
metafora di ciò che viviamo nella vita
di tutti i giorni momenti di paura di
incertezza ma anche momenti di
leggerezza di armonia
lo Yoga è equilibrio tra corpo e mente
lo Yoga ci aiuta a conoscerci nel
profondo ci aiuta a capire meglio le
nostre emozioni i nostri sentimenti e ci
aiuta a capire di cosa abbiamo bisogno
e lo Yoga è uno strumento che funziona
ma non perché ve lo dico io ve lo dice
Martina ve lo dice Claudia funziona
davvero non vi chiediamo di crederci
sulla parola ma adesso andremo a vedere
come anche in soli due minuti è
possibile cominciare ad ascoltarsi
davvero
andremo adesso a fare un esercizio molto
semplice nulla di strano imbarazzante
non vi preoccupate quello che vi
chiederò sarà di chiudere gli occhi
osservarvi e rispondere mentalmente ad
alcune domande
Ok cominciamo chiudiamo tutti gli occhi
Com'è il vostro respiro
lento o veloce
è superficiale
o profondo Quindi ripeto o di pancia
siete comodi o sentite il bisogno di
muovervi
riproviamo
Com'è il vostro respiro
lento veloce O come prima
è superficiale profondo o come prima
come si sente il vostro corpo comodo
scomodo o come prima
ripetiamo un'ultima volta
Com'è il vostro respiro lento veloce
O come prima
è superficiale profondo o come prima
il vostro corpo è comodo scomodo o come
prima
andiamo ora a fare tutti insieme Un
respiro profondo Quindi inspiriamo
ed espiriamo
e Apriamo gli occhi
come state
Chi di voi ripetendo Questo esercizio si
è sentito più rilassato
chi invece si è sentito più agitato
non c'è una risposta giusta o una
risposta sbagliata non c'è un risultato
unico per tutti alcuni di voi si sono
sentiti più rilassati e questo succede
perché quando portiamo l'attenzione
all'interno di noi stessi riusciamo ad
eliminare quegli elementi che non ci
fanno sentire a nostro agio
altri invece si sono sentiti più agitati
perché si sono resi conto di avere
qualcosa che gli stress e su cui non
riescono ad avere il controllo non
importa qualsiasi cosa abbiate provato
Siete riusciti a raggiungere lo scopo
dell'esercizio ascoltare voi stessi
lo Yoga è uno strumento che funziona ha
funzionato per noi e ha funzionato per
migliaia di persone che abbiamo avuto
modo di incontrare e che incontriamo
ogni giorno attraverso la nostra
Community e speriamo abbia funzionato
anche per voi oggi perché sì Anche
questo è fare yoga la cosa importante
però non è focalizzarsi sullo strumento
ma sull'obiettivo che esso ci aiuta a
raggiungere e cioè l'equilibrio
interiore quando riusciamo a svuotare la
nostra mente a eliminare ogni
distrazione iniziamo ad ascoltarci
davvero ad avere una conversazione
onesta con noi stessi
eliminiamo il contesto il rumore le
paure Per capire chi siamo e ciò di cui
abbiamo veramente bisogno
non vi chiediamo di tornare a casa
questa sera e pensare oggi comincio a
fare yoga o magari sì Eh quello che però
vorremmo Davvero è che ognuno di voi
cominciasse a cercare se non l'ha già
trovato qualcosa che lo porti ad
ascoltarsi davvero ad entrare in
profonda connessione con se stesso
qualcosa che ne guidi La Rotta
se oggi avessimo davvero l'opportunità
di incontrare in noi stessi del futuro
sicuramente troveremo delle persone
diverse da quelle che siamo qui oggi
perché il cambiamento è inevitabile ci
saranno delle volte in cui avremo il
controllo del cambiamento e altre in cui
dovremo accettarlo così come arriva
Il cambiamento non è per forza bene o
male
ma se è vero che il cambiamento non
porta per forza crescita e anche vero
che non ci può essere crescita se non
c'è cambiamento
ma allora qual è il messaggio che
vorremmo vi portasse a casa oggi
ascoltate voi stessi trovate la vostra
barca Grazie
[Applauso]